مع مثل هذه
الرئاسة الفاشلة والفاشلة ، يكاد يكون من غير المعقول أن
يفكر بايدن حتى في الترشح
لإعادة انتخاب
فعل
الضرر الذي ألحقه جو بايدن
بأمتنا في بضع سنوات قصيرة فقط.
بالنسبة لبلدنا ، فقد كان ذلك يعني
الكثير لأعدائنا عندما شاهدوا
ذلك الانسحاب الرهيب ، روسيا
تتعاون مع الصين ، إيران على بعد أيام من
تفجير قنبلة نووية ، ولم يكن حتى أوكرانيا التي يمكن تصورها قد دمرت بغزو لم
يكن ليحدث أبدًا
لو كنت رئيساً  وقد قادنا جو بايدن
إلى حافة الحرب العالمية الثالثة
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
بدعمكم في الانتخابات سنهزم
جو بايدن في عام 2024 ، وسننقذ
حسابنا وسنسحق
التضخم وسنوقف الغزو على
جنوبنا.  على الحدود ، سنستعيد
كرامة أمتنا وسنمنع
الحرب العالمية الثالثة من الحدوث معًا ،
وسنعمل جميعًا على جعل أمريكا عظيمة مرة أخرى شكرًا
لك